Is the microwave evil since I am on a low history diet and immediately freeze left over food. I use it to defrost so I don't have to cook every day.
I also make big batches of my coffee and a little more of it in the microwave is this okay.
Well, this is my opinion. So I use the microwave, you know, you know, a couple of my kids don't have a microwave in their house.
But my wife and I use the microwave.
And yes, does it, does it use waves that keep the coffee, you know, or the food, whatever you're heating up, you know, at a high level and couldn't denature the proteins.
And that's basically what the argument is, is it could denature the proteins in the food and it doesn't.
But, you know, it's again, it's like, it's like the iron microwave. It's like you can't, you know, we do a lot of things right.
I think my wife and I and our family do a lot of things right. But if we, you know, you can you see these Instagram posts of these people that are that are into healthy living it.
It's like, are you kidding? Is this how you actually live? Can anybody, this is your whole focus is on, you know, don't do this and do this and don't do this.
Your anxiety level must be through the lasted rule, you know, it's like you can't settle down and calm down and go, okay, well, this is the choice I'm going to make.
We're going to use the microwave. Maybe someday I'll go, hey, we're not going to use the microwave. We're going to use this.
But the truth is we cheat up leftover food all the time in the microwave and I have to heat up my coffee at the office three times in the microwave because I, you know, every time I make a coffee, I drink a little bit of it that it sits there and I forget about it.
I go heating up in the microwave and it sits in the microwave for an hour because I forgot I put it in the microwave.
You have to weigh things out on what you can do and can't do. Yeah, the perfect world would we not use the microwave? No, but probably not.
But in the world that we live in, you know, I probably shouldn't be on the computer all day. It's probably not going to vibrate either, but I have to because that's what I do.
You have to weigh those things out.